I I want to show this because Hillary
posted this vacation throwback and I
love this my kids we love is this Disney
is this Disney is that we are yes that
was Disney that was fun goes so often
it's so great it is great but we had we
had trauma and we had trauma on our trip
because every family does there's always
a breakdown well and and you know we I
think you were about four as I recall on
that trip and so we were taking a
shortcut behind you know one of the
buildings where the staff you know took
breaks
and
out walks Goofy
it takes off his head
this was I was very confused
it's just really this was an
earth-shattering moment we did we spent
hours trying to explain and and it was
like oh okay so that's not the real
goofy the real goofy somewhere else this
is somebody who's feeling it yeah we
tried right yeah yeah or like that
anyone maybe could be goofy like my
parents were really just throwing
everything possible explanation this is
exactly what I do I know you have to do
with your kids I I'll tell you backstage
how I run Frozen for my daughter and I
just I didn't get that she didn't know
that animation wasn't real it was just
very sad
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]